Come to think of it, even though I
was involved in an explosion that Kimura-kun, the creator of Yotsueda-kun, was involved in
, if time is rewinding, then that Anpan-kun is also rejuvenated, so even if he's rejuvenated, the bread
dough will be useful in some way.  No, no,
it's more of a raw material for white bean paste than before,
and it's noticeable now
, is
n't it
?  Did you know that
I made a carnivorous star that eats soybeans and eats rice as soon as I notice the sos signal that I used to eat soybean leaves as a decorative free mineral
?
I can't hear that voice
I'm going to eat it
9 I agree with the plan
9 It looks like a rough revenge play By the way, it's a tick I'm going
to make a detector that applies this valley sensor
But if you don't know the beans, the sos signal won't come out  Don't
you think that Kimura-san would eat the beanstalk just because the anpan suddenly turned into a bean
?  I'm already eating
Higuchi-kun, go back and ask me to finish the time accelerator
4th floor
Nice,
Kimura-kun, you really ate